do you ever see a story that makes you
fume that because you put yourself in
that situation and you'd be like what if
this happened to me check this out so
the moving company
came to like do this they got the sofa
stuck in the stairwell they just left
they were like yeah we can't
we can't do it so we're gone like can
you imagine they trying to move you in
and then they jacking up your couch your
walls now you have to get you have to
have a contractor come in and fix your
walls like there's no professional
moving school man the dude or lady that
runs the company and they're talking to
you and they're all like oh I'm so thank
you for using you know happy day moving
and it's always some dumb ass name like
that too to trick you good feeling
moving we always do it right moving so
you think oh okay you you know you
wouldn't name something like that if it
wasn't true it's never true they're
Liars okay they should be called Jack yo
up moving be leery of the people
moving moving company keep your eye on
these people
[Music]